jetzt ich bin vor einigen tagen habe ich
bereits auf das ankündigungs video
reagiert klasse und gestern ist es dann
passiert meine damen und herren katja
krasa wird das hier ist jedenfalls er
sie noch nicht kennen solltet sie hat
ihren ersten eigenen sorgen rausgebracht
auf ihrem youtube kanal und da muss ich
ganz ehrlich erstmal sagen ja kein
klatschen also im fond rausbringen das
macht nicht jeder mail talk ich habe
respekt davor werden leute sich
weiterentwickeln wenn youtuber vor allem
andere gebiete erforschen hat ja
erforscht allgemein oft glaube ich
gewisse gebiete aber das ist ein anderes
thema auf jeden fall habe ich respekt
davor wenn leute sich weiterentwickeln
also bei katja war es jetzt mehr oder
weniger zurückentwickeln hauptsache sie
hat gestern ging's raus ins all hat ist
direkt auf torwart disco pampa ist hans
palast will dorf
das sind die ja ich habe trainiert ja du
hast es geschafft
ich bin auch ein bisschen krank
ihre letzten videos trugen titel wie
beispielsweise so geht man richtig fremd
ja wenn ihr in der beziehung seit und
richtig gut fremdgehen wollt dann seid
ihr hier richtig aber freunde wir sind
nicht hier um jeden kanal irgendwie zu
analysieren sondern wir sind hier wegen
katja krawitz jockey deshalb haben sehr
viele youtuber darauf reagiert da war
meine stimme allerdings noch komplett am
arsch und ich mal bei meiner familie zu
hause und wollte dann ihrer zeit mit
ihnen verbringen
deswegen habe ich seit gestern quasi
keine youtube-videos mehr geschaut hat
mir noch keine rezension zu dem song
durch gewesen weil ich das jetzt
zusammen mit euch machen wollte also ich
würde sagen wir klicken jetzt einfach
mal drauf die seite öffnet sich und wir
sehen wir wo alter das sind nicht so
beschützende bewertungen oder [ __ ] warum
ist pause am rand als er das eine ganz
andere liga bevor wir uns den song
anhören würde ich sagen schauen wir uns
mal ein paar kommentare an besser als
bottrop
ja
wop bop kann mich bitte einer erschießen
vom flamenco
okay der bühne fast ja genauso scheiße
wie der müll von bibi
allemal besser als baby katja hat es
definitiv besser als baby gemacht das
ist krass also ich hätte jetzt nicht
gedacht dass die leute wirklich sagen
dass der song von katja besser sei als
der kombi war katja wird ihr eigentlich
noch mehr erhält als baby oder am black
friday kommt der song raus ist halt
alles billig an dem tag das ist ja das
aber meine damen und herren ich würde
sagen wir stützen uns auch jetzt mal
direkt in den song zuvor allerdings noch
ich habe nichts persönlich den katja
glaser witz ich habe mich noch nie mit
ihr persönlich unterhalten oder so
deswegen gehe ich jetzt komplett
unvoreingenommen in diesem jahr in
diesem action hier rein
[Musik]
die redet wie eine pornodarstellerin
also ich hab noch die pornodarstellerin
gesehen wie die reden aber die reden
halt alle mal sehr tief und sie halt
auch
so spielen wir auch immer karten katja
was jetzt sehen wir den attraktiven
pizzaboten der gerade hier an der tür
klingelt ich denke mal nicht dass das
katjas haus ist also aber wenn doch
katja herzlichen glückwunsch dass gerade
bruder ich hoffe dass der song nicht
losgelassen lied handelt jetzt nicht
wirklich davon dass die pizza wurden
verführt
wisst ihr
ich denke so die ganze zeit ich wache
beschissen callcenter komplett hatte
kratzer willst du setzt dich ganz
einfach nur mein tipp wisst ihr noch
ohne kondom
ich weiß nicht genau aber wir machen wir
weiter freude
das müsst ihr euch auf jeden fall selbst
anschauen also
schöner blick übrigens katja jetzt mal
real tag also ich habe ja schon auf
babys war bap reagiert damals und ich
denke jeder von euch hat auch abgesehen
und ungelogen das ist besser als ab ich
habe zu beginn gesagt dass ich komplett
unvoreingenommen dieses lied rein gehen
möchte einfach weil ich mir jetzt will
ich irgendwelche vorurteile gegenüber
dieser person haben möchte gegenüber
diesem lied nur weil man ihren content
hat kennt es kann ja sein dass sie
richtig gut singen kann ich muss sagen
es gibt deutlich bessere sängerinnen
aber es gibt auch deutlich schlechtere
sängerinnen wie beispielsweise babys
beauty palace
[Musik]
baby nichts gegen dich aber singen
kannst du tatsächlich gar nicht
[Musik]
ist der track ab 18
wir schauen mal
hier unten mehr anzeigen bla bla bla bla
bla die strophe ist komplett alleine
einige steht sogar stühle der stoffe
drin hier haben wir noch adressen für
geschäfts- anfragen keine fanpost
kathrin vogel
hierbei ist dass ihre adresse ein paar
sekunden später ich habe gerade mal die
adresse die unten bei ihren posten in
der beschreibung wie bei google
eingegeben und da kommt raus thai
massage bei you live bei einer straße 44
prenzlauer berg juli waxing sei einfach
schick haarentfernung in berlin
prenzlauer katja wissen es ja vielleicht
was sagen aber ist ja auch erst mal egal
was ihr noch so alles drin steht
ich würde sagen wir hören uns das ganze
liegt jetzt mal weiter an erreicht dann
auch
[Musik]
ihr könnt mir nicht sagen youtube dass
das hier nicht ab 18 sein muss es ist
komplett das ist komplett pflegeteam
youtube das da gebe ich euch definitiv
recht muss ich sagen ist gut das ist
guter beruf oder spaß ich feiere das
lied das ist einfach ein halber
softporno wie kann das nicht ab 18 sein
bis sie das wenn man
also freundschafts bücher bekommen hat
dann sollte man also die hobbys
eintragen und normalerweise war also die
standard-antwort schwimmen freude
treffen reiten keine ahnung was bei da
gestand er dann doch
ich will sex king katja was das denn für
die scheiße ich finde sowas von heißt
bei ihnen meine super geklappt
[Musik]
ok
nein
da habe ich dann der pause gemacht hat
er wirklich katja gerade gestört
ja
ja erhaltet hat
die story ist mein hobby du weißt dass
ich sex will es wird jetzt wild sowie im
sexfilm ich finde es so was von heißt
wenn du mir in meine pobacke kleist
das könnten drehbuch für einen porno
sein ich verstehe die räume auch nicht
hobby reibt sich auf gar nichts hier
will wild filme soll sich anscheinend
reihe also wir haben ja bbb reimen heiß
und kneift reibt sie auch nicht wirklich
also wir hätten hier a b c d e f rhein
wo sich nichts wirklich reimt stöhn lass
dich gehen ich für dich kommt packt mich
an und beruflich es wird schön dieser
abend und jetzt stehen meinen namen
katja
aber wir haben
doch nicht zuende angehört
[Musik]
mit dir der song ist die scheiße sorry
ich weiß ich nehme solche sachen immer
hoch und bei babys ab das war der
riesige angriffsfläche hier ist die
einzige angriffsfläche tatsächlich dass
das ganze video ein softporno ist und
das drehbuch ja auch aber real talk ich
für den song an sich nicht scheiße da
dass das fähig gewesen auf dieser party
also ich weiß nicht warum sie sich da so
komisch es ruckelt oder irgendwie so da
hätte man auch noch ein paar mehr leute
irgendwie hätten packen können die da
sich um dinge sind vor allem ich finde
ich auch einfach nicht geil
also ich weiss nicht viele zwölfjährige
die geil finde es einfach überhaupt
nicht mein typ
das hier ist tatsächlich das beste aus
dem ganzen video
die pizza hier unten
ja
ja das war's
das war doch der erste blick und der
erste kontakt ich schauen deine augen du
merkst werde ich schwach
a
ich laufe aus und ich will es jetzt ich
bin in stimmung und ich will sex aber
freunde wirklich zusammengefasst jetzt
mal ich muss sagen was ich jetzt auch
schon öfters in diesem video gesagt habe
das lied ist nicht komplette scheiße
also ich würde es mir nicht anhören ich
glaube ich dass es im radio laufen bin
ich glaube nie das was dir in die charts
stürmen wird aber für den ersten versuch
einen song zu machen und vor allem hat
sich dann wahrscheinlich auch das
unternehmen gedacht mit dem sie diesen
song gemacht hat ich weiß nicht genau
wer das war passte sich auch so ein
bisschen dem content an der künstler und
haben deswegen das ganze dorf genannt
und so ein bisschen mehr so in die soft
porno schiene rein fließen lassen ich
glaube die haben ganz guten fit gefunden
zwischen einem guten beat etwas nach
stimme die man sich eigentlich
normalerweise vielleicht sogar geben
könnte also katja mit autotür muss ich
sagen ist besser als viele andere
deutsche youtuber sänger sage ich mal
ich weiß nicht was ist eure meinung zu
dem lied streiks wohl gern bei uns in
die kommentare wird mich echt mega
interessieren weil ich dachte jetzt
wirklich jetzt kommt die größte kacke
aller zeiten so autotune fans des tores
und einen total bescheuert text nur
bestehend aus einsilbigen wörtern lieber
baby
[Musik]
aber es ging klar immer noch scheiße
aber nicht große scheiße
das war es jetzt jedoch familie meine
damen und herren wenn es euch gefallen
hat das gerne mal ein like da und
schreibt mal und in die kommentare eure
meinung zu dem song wird mich mega
interessiert ob ihr denn vielleicht auch
nicht so scheiße findet oder ob ihr den
komplett scheiße findet oder ob ihr euch
denn jetzt rund um die uhr an hört da
ich persönlich auch auf soundcloud aktiv
bin und dort regelmäßig mixtapes
raushauen wie ich selber musik zusammen
mixen von anderen künstlern setze ich
mich natürlich auch mit dem thema
auseinander selber mal musik zu
produzieren an der stelle nur noch mal
ganz kurz ich werde nie irgendwie singen
oder so ich möchte jetzt nicht so werden
wie andere youtuber und wenn ein
unternehmer kommt und sagt ey du kriegst
so viel geld dafür dass du singst dass
ich mich dann dafür hergeben oder so
weil ich weiß dass ich nicht singen kann
und ich mache mich so oft über andere
leute lustig das wird auch einfach nicht
so ganz passen aber ich setze mich hat
gerade daran selber so musik zu
produzieren so in die richtung martin
garrigues der kann ja auch überhaupt
nicht singen produziert dementsprechend
musik mit anderen künstlern zusammen
also da entwickele ich mich gerade so
ein bisschen weiter nur weil ich da auch
auf gefragt werde man mal musik von mir
kommt weil ich ja auf soundcloud immer
sehr aktiv bin aber deshalb mehr
elektronisch nicht was man im klub hört
zum feiern und so nicht so ja sowas
porno mäßig ist aber jetzt meine damen
herkommt das worauf man eigentlich die
ganze zeit wartet wenn man sich videos
von mir an schaut also da gibt es leute
die schauen sich tatsächlich videos von
mir an nur um das auto zu sehen
das kommt jetzt das ziel
wir können jetzt hier meinen kanal oder
meinen job ausschenken ihr findet ihr
zwei andere videos und managen abonnent
seid könnt ihr auf die glocke klicken
dann willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]